um first i want to thank sue chang for
inviting me um i've always enjoyed
talking with the computational science
community about my work
i was delighted when i received su
chang's choi invitation
now su chang took my course
on computational methods at stanford
many
years ago now i presume the purpose was
to learn
how computations can be used in
economics because she certainly didn't
need
any mathematical instruction for me but
certainly
being a student of michael saunders so
my
talk today is also aimed at giving you
a highly condensed version of what su
chang has heard
over the past many years about my
efforts
in uh bringing modern computational
methods
to economics um
now i always like to begin
uh talks particularly with economics
audiences to emphasize
how computation matters and one of my
favorite
examples of where computation screwed up
was the tacoma narrows bridge
collapsed in 1940 where basically
um engineers had
cont used a simple linearization
technique
to analyze the stability of a bridge
in the wind and this had worked
for a long time however because of
innovations
in the construction and design of the
bridge
um it turned out that there were higher
order non-linear effects
that were missed by the simple approach
and
led to this um this collapse
now the good news is
these engineers spoke with the experts
in uh in fluid dynamics structural
mechanics etc
and figured out how to do better job
and and we didn't see this again
the bad news is that the linearization
methods that were
behind the tacoma narrows bridge
collapse
is the basic
main tool that macroeconomists use
to analyze complex dynamic economic
systems
and this was the case even after the
great recession
um so that's a contrast
um between um computational engine or
engineering science and economics now
uh some of this may sound strange to you
particularly the older people in the
audience
there used to be a lot of collaboration
between economics
and computational scientists applied
mathematicians
for example ken arrow and milton
friedman both worked
in world war ii think tanks where they
worked on what we
now would call operations research
problems but
which did which involve computation and
which led to
breakthroughs and statistics ken arrow
and other economists in the 1960s worked
on
optimization theory problems and ragnar
frisch who was the
founder of the economic society and
econometrica
actually proposed barrier methods for
linear programming in the 1950s
now that didn't go anywhere because in
the 1950s
um you only had single precision
arithmetic and also you did not have
the kind of linear algebra software that
was
algorithms that was necessary to deal
with the instability problems
of barrier methods but anyway that was
an economist who was involved
in um developing in in the
computational science literature there's
been a little interaction in the last 40
years
now why do i say 40 years well um
economists when they were when they
teach constrained optimization they
always refer to the kuhn tucker theorem
and the kuntucker conditions whereas
um computational optimization people
mathematical obligation people
now call it the kkt theorem because
in the 70s the contribution of kerish
was discovered and then kuhn
and led an effort to then make sure that
this is called
kkt karish kuhn tucker but economists
had kind of disconnected themselves from
this world
by that time in the mid 70s when that
happened and
so you when you look at computational
writings of economists
you will see you'll see this that they
seem there seems to be a disconnect with
what's been going on
in the last 40 years the other thing is
that they love
matlab on laptops
and of course that greatly limits what
you can do
now what i have been working to show is
that modern computational science
hardware software etc tools can
potentially help advance
economics it's a potential this is not
consulting work where we know the answer
before we do the work
this is research and i'm confident
though that with enough research we can
turn that potential
into reality now i've been doing this
for a while um here's a about
14 years ago i
spoke at a department of energy town
hall
that was held at argonne and uh
the title my talk was potential
applications of exascale computing and
economics
and you see the um the write-up in the
scidac
review as a documentation of that
so this is um something i've been
reaching out to computational scientists
now i guess that was 14 years ago
so this can be thought of somewhat as a
progress report on that
effort that started about that time i
i hope that i can report a lot more
report in 2035
if i'm still here of course now
let's look at the ways that the u.s
government uses computational tools
and you will see the dramatic difference
between
economics and the rest of the us
government
now the national stockpile stewardship
program it has a mandate
the mandate is to make sure that if the
president united states wakes up one day
and wants to incinerate hundreds of
millions of people probably chinese and
russian
descent or maybe iranian whatever uh
that he can push a button and in 30
minutes they'll be incinerated
now by the way the russians and chinese
are doing the same thing
this all came out of the decision in the
early 1990s to stop nuclear testing
and then to use computer simulations to
assure the reliability of weapons
now the doe was given a computational
challenge
they said nuclear weapons simulations
must extrapolate
far beyond the available data and must
predict
coupled multi-scale physical phenomena
that are difficult
to isolate in experiments and congress
demanded that the administrator for
nuclear security shall develop and carry
out
a plan to develop executable computing
now those guys
they took their mandate seriously and
they got a lot of money
and so this is um
this was a machine that they had uh
about 10 years ago it's called sky
bridge
uh now by the way whoever came up with
that name
um has a i know a sick sense of humor
as well as a boss who hadn't seen the
terminator movies
which uh was based which talked about
the skynet
computer um but then that's an old
computer sky bridge and now we have more
recently sierra
neither one of them is exoscale yet but
of course
um there is the aurora project going on
at argonne
um so we we are aiming in that exit
scale direction now let's contrast that
the u.s federal reserve the
they have a mandate also their mandate
is to
have prac determined ensure price
stability
full employment also they are the lender
last resort and in the past decade
they also have acquired a lot of
responsibility in terms of regulating
financial institutions
and regulating systemic risk
now my view is that they should also
have a mandate
to use economic policy simulations
because they must also extrapolate far
beyond available data
they must also predict coupled
multi-scale social and economic
phenomena
that cannot be isolated in experiments
and so this sounds like their their
mandate also
is an appropriate use for high power
computing what computational tools
does the fed use that
is what the fed uses laptops
and then a econometric software package
called eviews the main
macro model used by the fed is something
called fervis frb
us and it is basically a
slightly non-linear set of equations
that are
solved by code written up um
uh in e-views code um
and all handmade by hand written but
coded up by somebody at the fed
who has no credentials in writing up
software
and uh why do they choose this well
because it's easy to do programming and
to create graphs in the same code
that was an answer i got and then when i
pointed out that there are many ways you
can do that they stopped
answering my questions um but that's
that's what the fed started using in
1996 and continue today
um so they aren't you know that's what
they use
um now my attitude is that the fed has a
real job and substantial resources this
isn't
they aren't just a bunch of economic
professors blabbing on and on about this
or that
etc they've got a real job to do and
they've got lots of money
they spend about 50 million a year i
think on their research staffs at
various feds
regional feds a lot of young people
there want to have the training and the
hardware
to do serious work now the fed has a
i would not want their job i mean to
manage the monetary policy and they
economic policy that's a
very difficult time job requiring a lot
of judgment
but when the organization doesn't really
care
about being good at doing the arithmetic
behind their judgments
i wonder how careful they are at doing
their
when it comes to judgments that's the
challenge
that i've made to them now some of you
may
recall from history course the um uh
famous 1896 speech of william jennings
bryan
where he said again argued it's gold
standard and argued saying that you
shall not crucify mankind and
bond across a goal um
that was the kind of rhetoric 125 years
ago
um but i wonder if he were here today
we'd have no gold standard anymore but
what would he say
about monetary finance financial policy
analysis at the fed
this millennium being based on laptops
using minuscule computing power
obviously using obsolete
homemade code that's the situation we're
in today now
okay so that's um the challenge i have
laid down for economists um
now i've had some success in using
modern computational tools and economics
and so today i will go over uh some of
them
um for you giving you a quick overview
of um of the things i worked on now
here is one project that i worked on for
many years
um it's
what is the up what's the optimal carbon
tax in a world
in the world now this was a question
that has been
discussed now for uh many years
um nordhaus's first work on this goes
back to um
early 90s i believe kevin hassett had a
paper even before that
now in 2010 um
there was a joint effort on the part of
many agencies of the federal government
to determine the social cost of carbon
and uh they'd come up with a number i
forget what exactly it was um but anyway
they came up with
a plot of numbers of what the optimal
carbon tax would be throughout this
century
now um the the model they use to
describe the climate
and the economy was very simple
everything was deterministic
that is everybody knew with perfect
certainty the path of the economy and
the climate given
carbon emissions okay that's a problem i
don't like that assumption
furthermore when it came time to
discretize
the differential equations that model
the climate um the concentration of
carbon
uh the diffu the heat diffusion of heat
etc uh they used
a novel finite difference method
to approximate the differential equation
what they did is they used 10-year time
steps
so they discretized time with units of
10 years
furthermore their discretization implied
that
co2 emitted 10 years from now
would start heating the earth now
i refer to that as uh time traveling co2
now what i and my collaborators showed
is that this created about
i don't know about a 15 to 30 percent
error in the
uh their um optimal carbon tax numbers
i'm higher than that they should have
been um now was this some kind of
liberal
conspiracy by left-winging greens
uh no it was just that these guys just
didn't know
how to discretize differential equations
now
so what i and my collaborators i list
the two main ones here young yang kai
who's now at ohio state and thomas
loncich who now
is at the university of akron by the
time we did this they were both
postdocs um and so what we did is we
we wanted to look at what is the optimal
carbon
tax in the world but where there's
riskiness there's uncertainty
we we don't know where the economy is
going to be over the next hundred years
we don't know where it's going to be
tomorrow there's a lot of uncertainty
in in the economy that has nothing to do
with the climate nothing to do
with anything except it's just very
uncertain
economists model the underlying dynamics
of the economy as essentially a random a
brownian motion with some drift
it's it's not a straight line that can
be perfectly predicted
so we added that we went to a model that
had that
kind of uncertainty in there
then also we added things like um
uncertainty on the climate side
for example uh the increasing
um temperatures is going to speed up
melting of glaciers but again we don't
know the time scale which that's going
to happen
so we used expert opinions to calibrate
that
so we did this and we called it dynamic
stochastic
integration of climate and economy and
here's a picture of the model i normally
hate pictures but when
thomas drew this i said that's a good
picture so the economy creates emissions
it goes
emissions go in the atmosphere emissions
of co2 and then the emission the
co2 gas um diffuses between the
atmosphere upper ocean and deep ocean
and then in the atmosphere the co2 uh
creates um interactions with uh
radiation and and um sorry heat have
increased temperature of the atmosphere
which then also increase the temperature
in the ocean
and then the higher temperature damages
the economy
now what we added is a stochastic
feedback a sarcastic element here that
how much damage a higher temperature
does is itself a stochastic and uh
process
also we also said the economy is subject
to stochastic shocks
um and then what happens how do we
control this well we have mitigation
policies
that to put a lid on emissions this by
the way
is those of you know about nordhouse's
dice model this is the same as
nordhouse's dice model um and he got the
climate part here he got after talking
with uh
schneider famous climate scientist
um here at stanford many years ago and
but we added this uncertainty stuff
now by the way what that does is that
transforms a control
the problem from optimal control of a
differential equation to optimal control
of partial differential equations
that's what that transformation does
um now those of you who know about
dynamic programming will recognize this
as a bellman equation
um i'm not going to go through all these
equations but this is
a basically um discrete time optimal
control where you have uncertainty
um this is a discrete time version of
hamilton jacobi bellman equations
um this is also a discrete time version
of what's called backwards stochastic
differential equations
uh the key thing is that if there's the
state vector is eight dimensional
now what i like to tell um guys that
work in pdes is
uh you're probably tired of working with
three spatial dimensions aren't you
see we have eight so um
you know that means we we can give you
an excuse for taking
what your 3d methods for solving uh 3d
um diffusion equations and then expand
them to five six
seven or eight so that's where economics
is different
it's likely to be higher dimensional
problems
however it is in in this case it's kind
it's like controlling a diffusion so we
aren't going to have shock waves like
with um
hyperbolic pdes it's going to there's a
smoothing element here from the
diffusion
a diffusion operator so going to higher
dimensions is um
is possible and so we um
solved it it's basically a difference
equation a bonus base
um you have a terminal time and you
solve backwards
and this is what the biggest example in
the published paper
the the paper came out in december 2019
in jpe which is one of the top journals
in economics
um now the largest exam we have many
examples in the paper the largest one
um nine dimensions um
it was we saw with parallelization
um we used 84 000 cores which took eight
hours
if we just had a single laptop we'd take
77 years and
my post docs wanted to get a real job
before 77 years passed
um so i wanted to get something done
before because i'm not going to be
around in 77 years
and now what these numerical dynamic
programming problems amount to is
you solve you know millions of
optimization problems and then you hit a
parallel block
and then you solve it then once that
parallel block has been resolved
you have millions of little optimization
problems again and then there's a
parallel block
um because we have good load balancing
the parallel block is not a problem
in fact on this problem um young yang
did some
scaling and it's get the time scaled
linearly from 10 000
to 20 000 to 40 000 80 000 course so
this was something that passed the
critical scaling test of does it belong
on a supercomputer
also um when we did um some flops count
uh we found that it was
ten percent a peak which we're told by
supercomputer people is pretty good
so that's the kind of computational
resources we used
this is a computer we used blue waters
which was
the um uh leading edge
nsf uh supercomputer for a while
it's now um been supplanted by i believe
the machine in texas but anyway these
things only lie
you know they they last for five six
years and then they become obsolete
but we had it we we used it for about
over course about five or six years
we got about 20 million car hours um
and we we used we used it
um now how did we use it well one thing
about economics is
you don't know what the parameters are
you know physics is
easy you have a c you have a
gravitational constant you can
weigh measure the mass of things the
speed of light
c squared that's tied down very well
um the fine structure constant is tied
down to 10 digits whatever
so you guys in physics you you know the
parameters
of your models however when it comes to
economics
we have theories about how people make
decisions but we don't know exactly what
demand curves and supply curves are
following
we don't know exactly the parameters in
the underlying economy
one reason is that we don't have enough
data to pin it down
the other reason is that these are
people
and people are a lot more complicated
than particles
and people change over time so you
you've got a fuzzy kind of situation
that doesn't mean that you can't use
computation what we do is we look at the
key parameters
in the model and then we we look at what
what what is a good range of values
reasonable values
for those parameters like the discount
how much do people discount the future
relative to today
and so we looked at uh discount rates of
0.2 percent up to 1.4
annually um and then
lambda is the mean growth rate um
and also q is damages how much
we don't know exactly what the damage is
going to be and of course the thing is
that in these models
the climate sensitivity is a parameter
in the climate side that
we have little information about
so here's a four-dimensional graph so
basically
um in this block if q is zero or low
damages
growth rate is slow then um along
this line in discount climate
sensitivity rate along this line
um the optimal cost uh social cost of
carbon in
2010 is 40 along this science 80 etc
so you see that we can show you you know
for a while for an affordable this is
basically a four-dimensional graph
um we can show you how the the
underlying parameters affect
the what the social cost of carbon could
be and yes there are some places where
you got big numbers but they involve
um very high climate sensitivities um
as well as very low utility discount
rates and people often argue well that's
not
plausible typically people are going to
argue for
numbers that are sort of the upper
left-hand corner of all these boxes
and so you see you could kind of get a
consensus roughly about
what the social cost of carbon is first
of all 40
is like a minimum um and then even
even if you're on the conservative side
of beliefs um
uh it's it's a range of 40 80
now by the way when i gave that talk um
at argonne many years ago
somebody asked um
uh are you sure you can use
these computational tools to pin down
exactly what the optimal monetary and
power
tax policies are and i said no
we we don't know the world with great
precision
um to pin down exactly what the policies
are
what we can do and this is by the way
the job of a lot of economists that go
to washington dc
is what we can do is we can sort of
identify what are really
dumb ideas what are really bad ideas
that's what computation can do
is to narrow the range of
policies to some range that has some
plausible value
and and many times you put in a policy
that
somebody comes up with and you put into
a computational model and then you can
use that to say
look look this is a crazy policy it
doesn't work it backfires etc
that's what computation can do is to
narrow the range of of
arguments i've been at conference i was
um
once invited to be part of a panel um
that met with uh treasury secretary
whoever it was in 2007.
um i forget these guys um paulson
and so the panel of public finance
economist
talked with paulson and i look around
the table and listen to what people say
i can't tell the difference between
republicans and democrats
because when you in a professional
environment the the
the we have common sense of basic
beliefs and views
um yes there's arguments but you know
when you put the professionals together
they they can be dis those rangers can
be disciplined
and nobody comes up with idiotic ideas
that says oh we
cut tax rates and revenues go up you
know that kind of stuff that's in the
political domain not in the academic
domain
so that's what the goal here of mine is
is to
force economists policymakers etc to
write down what are their assumptions
and then see what the implications are
and a lot of times
the implications are different than what
they hoped they would be and this is
what's
going on here with this uh climate
change uh work
um now um let me
okay so uh what we see here
is this is um
this is an example of how our approach
can
alter thinking um in the world
of um the ipcc for example they love to
talk about scenarios
what's likely to happen and so the rcp
8.5
is a scenario that they think is
what would happen if there's no
intervention that the surface
temperature over this century will rise
to be almost five degrees above what it
was
um at some earlier time um
at some base time now we show is that
when you add the uncertainty of the
economy to it
there's a strong chance you know that
that
their scenario gets sort of the
expectation right
but the thing is that um this broke this
is 75
quantile so 7 25 chance that it's above
5 degrees
and then a 10 chance that's above 6
degrees
and and this is the problem with talking
about climate change
we don't know what's going to happen but
it's the extreme events that we have a
lot to fear
and that's what we should focus on so
anyway that's um
i'm okay that's one area where we've had
some success in i
throw you so some other side some other
slides
of what we've done here's a more recent
example
of what we're doing multi-objective
optimization
now if we're going to talk about optimal
policies
optimal tax policies for example the
social planner
whatever they have to worry about
getting enough revenue to pay the bills
they have to worry about the utility
of the taxpayers and of their
politicians the impact on distribution
now of course engineers face the same
thing when they design an airplane
there's multiple pieces to an airplane
and you have to
look at what happens when you combine
the ultimate
alternative choices for the design this
is all what's called multi-objective
optimization where you have multiple
objectives
and the the object the purpose of
multi-objective optimization is to tell
you what the pareto frontier is
so there's all sorts of stupid things
that you can do to have low utility and
low revenue
but what you're looking for is a
frontier where you have the maximum
revenue given a particular level of
maximum given a particular level of
utility that's what we want to do
and one thing you can write down is a
constrained documentation problem
the problem is these things are ugly
nasty constrained optimization problems
really bad non-convex it's
really bad so what we do um
with this is with a couple of students
um i've been working with
is we just sample from this is an
example of a simple economy
where we look at taxes on interest
and taxes on wage rates and we look at
the for the pareto frontier and then
each of these dots
this is the pareto frontier and here is
the tax on capital
so that on the pareto frontier the tax
on capital is always basically zero
on labor as you need more and more
revenue
it gets redder and redder and so so
basically what this says is that
here here's the this here's a scatter
plot of all the possible combinations of
taxes
two kinds of taxes you look at the
freighter frontier and you realize
eh you don't want to tax interest income
it's a it's a
inferior policy now that was a brute
force thing and then now we're using uh
this
with philip muller we're using more
homotopy path following methods
um to find the parador frontier and
here's
an example there we have three kinds of
taxes we look at
interest income tax labor income tax and
consumption tax
what we find again is that when we plot
out here's the utility versus revenue
parador frontier
again when we look at the pareto
frontier capital tax is always zero
the labor and consumption tax can be
mostly anything but that's because the
kind of perfect substitutes for each
other
so you can't there's no such thing as an
optimal labor tax or an optimal
consumption tax
you have a big menu and so why would we
argue over it we have lots of arguments
over these things
but this says that in this particular
case uh no point in arguing
um because the differences are of of no
importance
so that's um and within the um
uh within
this multi-objective optimization
what's going on is this given a tax
policy vector tower
and some performance vector this could
be
utility on average over people or this
is utility of the people that voted for
you
or the utility of people that didn't
vote for you whatever
um what you do is you compute you take
a set of vectors a set of taus policy
and then compute this these performance
criteria on that grid perhaps using
quasi-monte carlo
sampling because there's gonna be a
multi-dimensional sampling grid
and then you take that data and you
construct an approximation of this
function that maps the policy to the
performance criteria
and how do we do that well we could use
neural nets sparse grids dictionaries
shareless whatever you know it's an
approximation problem
so this is like a big data problem
except i don't have to deal with mother
nature
mother nature is not nice whatever data
she gives you it's all
noised up errors everywhere she gives
you a lot of data where you don't want
it and then not as much data where you
do want it
you're you're a prisoner to the whatever
data process mother data
mother nature came up with no i have big
data problems but i control the data
i choose where i evaluate um the
performance of tao
um and so i don't have those problems
because i control the data process
in order to get this approximation of a
function
by the way this is asynchronously
parallelizable
but you can also use low latency
communication this is ideal for
high power computing um
now i have uh you know i want to talk
about
one place where collaboration real with
mathematicians really helped mechanism
design
began with merley's 1971 paper on
optimal taxation
he won a nobel prize for that
now the problem with that theory is that
i'll
speak in terms of optimization
description
you have n variables and choices with
n squared constraints and it's
non-linear
i know it doesn't matter if it's a
linear program no this is non-linear
you have massive failure of level icq
linear independent constraint
qualification and so when chaelin sue
and i
worked on this many years ago 15 years
ago
none of the solvers worked as a few kind
of worked a little bit
but they all ultimately crashed on this
failure of lacq
um and then i got the attention of
michael saunders
um and a student of his uh ding monk
and they told me oh ken we can handle it
it's easy it's easy oh yeah we got these
well so we met several times nothing
they suggested worked
and then they went away and i thought
okay they've given up on this
six months after they went away they
came back and said hey ken here's a
paper
where we solved it and here's the paper
stabilized optimization by an ncr
algorithm so um you can those of you
interested in the optimization stuff can
look at it
but this was a case of where in
economics
this very important kind of problem has
a massive
degeneracy um but um
and my name is on the paper only because
i basically bugged the mathematicians
about how your stuff doesn't work
um which i thought was kind of nice if i
bugged the economist about stuff
not working they'd definitely go to hell
but no the mathematicians took this as a
challenge
and they delivered and so now we have a
tool to examine a
wide range of phenomena that we weren't
able to before
now um i'm going to skip through the
next couple things or
um solving polynomial systems economists
just always use linear demand curves
linear supply curves
ah because you know the lines cross
linear systems are easy to solve
but you give up a lot of realism when
you go to line
straight linear systems um my friends
and i have used
things like bertini and phc pack both of
which have a chicago area origin
also um i and a student of mine are
working on
use applying modular group no basis
methods with
supercomputing um to get robner bases
all of this is highly parallelizable um
and this can basically take us to
solving far more realistic systems
particularly
in antitrust analysis etc
um now um
so oh i'm actually gonna hit
my 40 minute mark um computational
science is moving ahead
very rapidly one thing i plotted out for
another um
presentation was you know we all know
about moore's law
you know speed is increasing at a
doubling every two years
what's amazing is that the cost of a
gigaflop
is falling more rapidly than that if you
look at the cost
of a gigaflop from 1980 until 2020 or
you actually i think the numbers were
actually 1985 to 2017.
the cost is falling at a speed a hundred
times
faster than moore's law says this uh
chip
speed is increasing and to an economist
it's a cost that matters
we now have massive parallelism gpus
cloud computing high throughput
computing
new algorithms for a variety of things
um oh by the way i should say um i
forgot to mention this
um we are using python
uh oh yeah uh philip mueller is using
python
to do this um the other stuff
was mostly fortran but that's because we
started you know
10 years ago before python was around
even
um so um there's new software
like python to use um i use mathematica
a lot
um so the the the range of software
tools is exploded
algorithms have exploded in terms of the
variety and their power
and economics is not using it
and so i'm not i my my point of this
talk
is to show you not so much brag about
what i've done
but about how much i haven't done
but that with your help could do a lot
we could do
a lot more and a lot better thank you
thank you ken that's a very uh
interesting talk uh we have one question
in the chat uh from
fred uh hey canal oh
yeah now you know typical um the thing
is with
questions like yeah he's asking for your
basic task slide can you indicate what
the typical dimension of tao is
how much data can you afford to
approximate um
the problem that um we're
aiming at in with i'm working on with
phil that is kind of like
a a big problem a major problem
is ten dimensions um basically it's
we're trying to look at a piecewise
linear income tax code
so so piecewise linear with five
brackets and then five um
uh break points that's ten dimensions
and um that is i think um
uh for a lot of these for that problem
that you need you need that many
dimensions
um but now 10 dimensions and using
uh quasi-monte carlo methods we can
probably do a
10 dimensions is not a enormous range to
get a nice
a nice sample of um of points in 10
dimensions
now um how much data can you afford
to approximate your you know the thing
is that
right now don't
i don't know how much data i'm going to
need
um i i don't the the thing is right now
that uh
for the tent for that that income tax
case
um i'm sure we're going to need billions
of trillions of little
cows or cases you see with each towel
then we have a lot of different kinds of
people
so we may have like a a million
different towels and then
have like a thousand different kinds of
people and so that's a billion
combinations there uh but the thing oh
by the way here's the key magic here
once you specify a policy tao
and an individual the demand and supply
curve essentially
then it's a convex optimization problem
and so uh so those things are fast
those things are lightning fast um
so i think um the
um that's
that i'm not worried about i i'm not
worried about uh
not having about needing too much data
the thing is that surface
is going to have it's it's going to be
piecewise c
infinity but there will be places where
there are kicks and even discontinuities
now okay so that's why i have to
hesitate can i find those
discontinuities and kinks in high
dimensional space
i don't know but remember the focus here
is going to be on pareto efficient
combinations of policies
and so um a lot of times these
kings and whatever are going to be in
regions of the policy space that are
totally irrational
so um uh but yeah there's gonna be
problems
um approximating this and um
neural nets may come in handy basically
it's we have to find out
this this is where it's researched and
exploration
um okay so uh
jim plaque are you familiar with a book
i'm sorry can i just follow up again i
just didn't quite understand normally
when you want to approximate a function
rather than just
evaluate it and be happy with what the
values it's because the functions
expensive so you're constructing a
surrogate model but you tell me you're
going to have billions of values that
doesn't sound like you want a surrogate
model
well i'm just saying that um
the amount of use that i'm going to make
of that function
is going to be it's going to be far more
economical for me to solve let's say
like a billion cases
than to then go to an application and
then use a circuit
and then go to an application and
variety of applications
where i needed to go then do trillions
of quadrillions
so no i understand yeah so the thing is
that the thing about this
surrogate function is that i'm thinking
of using it for a variety of purposes
for example predicting you know like if
there's a elect if there's a vote
between policy one or policy two it can
be used for that
so the the purpose the having this one
surrogate function
can then be used for a variety of
applications
in political science analysis what i'm
talking about
um so no i see your point but the thing
is that
in economics that surrogate function can
have an enormous
variety of uses and so the surrogate
approach is appropriate
um i am not familiar with radical
uncertainty
decision making beyond um
numbers now um my
my initial response is
how do you go beyond numbers in
economics i mean
um now what
um here's here's uh
a quote from lbj
and for you young people when old guys
like me say lbj
i'm not talking about lebron james i'm
talking about
lyndon baines johnson okay i've had to
make that distinction sometimes in
speaking with the young people uh so
some economists came to him and gave him
them a range of their predictions about
what could happen
and lbj said i don't want ranges ranges
are for cattle give me a number
well that's a problem in in
with in a lot of contexts people want a
number a number a number
we're going to have to like get them
away from that because
there is no one number that summarizes
any research it's a range of numbers
so um so that's what i think
um what what i have some
expertise in is helping people
understand what a reasonable range of
numbers
are for predictions of what policies
work and what they don't
um i'll have to take a look at that what
he means by it's f
it's very popular say oh i go beyond
numbers
you go beyond numbers what are you doing
yeah i think
mervyn uh king is one of the authors i
think he's from the london school of
economics oh yeah
no i i've even seen mervyn talk a couple
times met him yeah
he's challenging i think uh
expectations that are being placed upon
the models and
uh the single number aspect that you
just mentioned with respect to lbj
also figures into it and he's
distinguishing between what he calls
small world models
which are models that have a finite
number
of states finite number of outcomes
finite number of parameters
and then contrasting those with what he
calls
big world models which are
economics issues where you cannot
perfectly model
uh an individual's behavior or a
society's behavior and i think he's
asking us to have a little bit
less confidence in the
numbers that these models are absolutely
like i said uh in 2007 i have no
belief that i can tell you what the
exact policy is
what i hope to be able to do is identify
bad ideas
and uh i think what's needed on the part
of economists is a
um a lot more modesty um
now by the way um i also like to remind
physicists when they talk about how
great physics is that
i believe at last time at last count
they could only under they only
understand five percent of the mass and
energy in the universe
so um the rest is dark anyway so
many many fields have
some ranges of uncertainty and you have
to focus on what you can do and what you
can analyze and what you can
think about um i think for example the
the financial crisis of 2008 and i think
many people would agree with this
was a direct consequence of this gross
over-reliance on some free market
ideology
um that took over that basically swept
away a lot of sensible
um regulation in the late 90s and um
they they had they had it was an
ideology without any numbers behind it
many of us could imagine that
could have come up with models to say
that you know this isn't such a good
idea
always so um that's i think the case of
where
the lack of modesty and the domination
of ideology really hurt
and um and so that's what i'm
now by the way i'm at the hoover
institution everybody thinks i'm a
hardcore
right-wing republican no i'm a lifelong
democrat maybe on the conservative side
but anyway
so he has some interesting conversations
with uh
mr soul mr soul doesn't have
conversations with most anybody
he's a very reclusive person
um so uh
i i did have some great conversations
with ed teller
um many years ago um
and with many other people uh so no it's
um
it's it's a lot more open-minded than
you might then than the image is um
so um and that's you know within that
context that people understand yes we
we don't have enormous con we don't have
total confidence in
everything um that the pure theory says
and and uh yeah the thing is oh
one of my professors in graduate school
was
a guy named buzz brock william brock
and one thing he said to me is that you
know mathematicians
uh have seen all of the assumptions
that are behind the free market
economics ideology and that's why
they tend not to be conservatives and
free market advocates
they've seen all the assumptions that go
into
uh argument the the standard chicago
style
um economics that's a lot of assumptions
it's a good starting point but to be the
end point is not a good idea
and no you have to realize that
the world is not perfectly competitive
with
um with zero transaction costs and all
sorts of other
um simplifying assumptions and but this
but one reason why
economics really is stuck in the simple
world is because it refuses
to do this um kind of analysis
it it's stuck in um the second
millennium where you had
everything had to be done basically in
pencil and paper
um and whereas you know you look at
papers written in economics in the 1970s
and then what the written today the
mathematical complexity
is surprisingly similar um
they it just they just haven't
adopted the um 40 years of progress in
computational science and applied math
and that's what i've been trying to do
so yeah follow-up question
why do you think that is that's not a
suitable topic for a scientific talk
now one thing i want to by the way my i
think my official time is
close to coming to an end um i will be
here
um until 7 30 your time um
but um i just want to end by saying you
know
i welcome more conversations on this
um i hope this is just the beginning of
many conversations
with this audience um and um
i i don't i anyway
if you don't have my email address just
do a google search for kenneth judd
you should find my web page somewhere
maybe su chang can send out my
my um my email address actually
one of the email addresses is easy
kenneth judd mac.com
the other one isn't hard either judd
stanford.edu but anyway
please if you have any comments
questions um
email me um i
love to take up many more topics of
conversation
with all of you um but i think this
is the official end of uh
this converse of this presentation and i
thank you
but after soo chang is done then with
the official and then
i'm still here well fast
ken um there are two more questions uh
in the chat window uh one more from jim
okay
what is your view in the current state
of
well okay okay um
well okay machine learning in economics
is largely confined
to empirical work um
i have some colleagues at stanford that
do a lot of this
um and they they um
[Music]
they they basically are using um
machine learning deep learning um to
um to analyze data
in a sort of basically what they're
doing is a fancy
a fancy version of regression one thing
i'd like to point out to economists they
start
what they read all the propaganda in
neural nets and all that and i see
it's just another form of non-linear
regression
and um and so that's
that's um now one reason i say that is
because i remember
the the big rise in popularity of neural
nets in the 1980s and then that bubble
burst
so anyway um now
there are some friends of mine they're
using neural nets to
solve basically in science some people
are
using neural nets to solve partial
differential equations and then some of
these things
i've been talking about are kind of like
solving pds and so could
neural nets can be used to do that i
don't know how good that that method is
going to be
um but we'll see um
no i think the machine learning and i
mean it's
like i said a lot of this is
very advanced powerful ways
of approximating a surface given the
data you have
and so that's how i view all of these as
just um
um better ways than orthogonal
polynomials for many reasons
better way anyway so better than free
approximately but i put them all in that
and in fact in the next uh edition of my
book i'm going to have
two chapters on approximation classical
methods of approximation and modern
methods of approximation
um because um but it's all approximation
you have data you have points
and then you try to find some manifold
of some dimension that
that represents it um there was another
okay regarding next steps what is your
car
that's for another conversation that's
to email me
no i mean i i think there's like like
the story with michael saunders and
digma and
um orban i mean it's a great example of
how
um collaborations can yield to progress
for both um computational math
and for economics uh if you want to hear
more about my call to action and um
uh follow my blog in the next starting
in a couple months
but no um right now i mean if anybody
has some ideas
related to this just contact me and we
can we can chat